elle écoute la java
elle entend la java
elle a fermé les yeux
mais toi
merci Nicole dans profil là
tu fais cette année tes 30 ans de
carrière qu'est-ce que tu te dis là
en fait je reviens toujours pas à la
base je voulais être comédienne ce que
j'ai fait d'ailleurs donc j'ai avec mon
toupet je suis allé jusqu'au théâtre
dollars et puis bon bah ça ça a marché
et puis j'ai fait des rencontres juste
fabuleuses quoi donc c'est ce qu'il y a
c'est ce qui a fait de moi aussi ce que
je suis aujourd'hui c'est ce qui m'a
forgé aussi quelque part
quand mes petits
[Musique]
sapin
lavé même point
dimanche
avec les mourir
réchauffer des
combats pendant 30 ans ils sont passés
des choses comme on dit il y a de l'eau
qui a coulé sous les ponts quoi donc et
il y a eu il y a eu du bon il y a eu du
très bon il y a eu du mauvais et du très
mauvais et
comme j'aime à dire ce mauvais il est
peut-être aussi nécessaire justement
pour cheminer en fait pour aller
vraiment d'un point A à un point B je ne
dis pas que c'est simple je ne dis pas
que j'y suis arrivé mais j'y travaille
je continuerai je continuerai avec le
premier titre qu'on a pu découvrir en
clip tegor là c'est un hommage à Arnaud
Dormeuil oui ça fait partie des
merveilleuses rencontres que j'ai pu
faire aussi
dans ta carrière une base je sais pas
comment on pourrait si quelqu'un qui m'a
appris la rigueur qui m'a dit que voilà
il y a que en travaillant qu'on peut y
arriver quoi c'est pas tu te lèves le
matin et hop ça part quoi tu vas bosser
Tu vas chercher tu vas creuser les
choses et puis tu vas au bout des choses
et c'est quelqu'un qui pourrait me
montrer que avec une différence physique
cette chose que tu peux considérer comme
un handicap en fait cette chose on te
montre du doigt limite et que tu as de
choix
tu es hors norme et tu as deux choix où
tu te planques et puis dans ce cas là tu
acceptes tout ce qu'on peut te t'envoyer
tous les jours et puis tu te taire et tu
ne bouges plus ou tu te dis bah
ça c'est leur pensée c'est leur façon de
voir ça leur appartient moi j'ai autre
chose à proposer j'ai autre chose à dire
[Musique]
énormément
est-ce qu'il y a eu un moment marquant
dans ta carrière qui a fait que tu as
décidé de poursuivre qu'est-ce qui t'a
dit faut que je me professionnalise
parce que toi tu as eu une carrière ou
voilà il a fallu jongler et beaucoup de
chance en fait parce que
à chaque fois que je prenais un boulot
standard j'ai envie de dire tout me
ramener en fait à la scène tout me
ramener mais tout tout comme par hasard
j'arrive dans une boîte c'était vendu
j'arrivais là-bas il y a je te dis mais
pourtant c'est dans des grosses poils je
comprends pas là il y a enfin bon et en
fait j'avais pas compris que l'univers
me disait et
donc arrête de de d'essayer plein de
choses et de pas aller jusqu'au bout en
plus puisque c'est là qu'il faut que tu
y ailles c'est ça en fait qui m'anime le
fait de pouvoir aller donner de l'amour
aux gens j'ai une maman un jour qui m'a
écrit qui m'a dit que sa fille elle
était totalement elle était pas bien
limite dépressive et qu'elle avait
besoin d'écouter une de mes chansons
tous les matins pour pouvoir se lever
et tu te dis waouh
tu sais pourquoi tu te réveilles le
matin tu sais pourquoi tu fais tous ces
sacrifices parce que ça vient aider
aussi les gens à se lever mon dieu
mon dieu
[Musique]
mon Dieu
laissez-le moi encore un peu mon amour
[Musique]
ce qu'on aime chez toi c'est ce sourire
et tes yeux qui pétillent finalement
[Musique]
donc voilà c'est l'amour du public parce
que 30 ans après j'ai toujours un public
qui répond présent
il y a pas de plus beau cadeau c'est
extraordinaire donc gratitude totale
quoi merci beaucoup Nicole merci c'est
Greg à très bientôt